See, look here, DeMar
Draymond’s on LeBron again...
Yeah, it’s like a triple switch or something
Exactly...
What are you reading?
We’re studying.
House Warriors' defensive tactics against King James
It wasn’t their tactics.
It was their talent.
We have the talent.
We just need smart strategy
and for the gods to finally smile on us.
Maybe they have
DeMar! This is our chance!
King James is gone from our path,
but he is also gone from our excuses.
If we fail to conquer the East this year…
it could be the end for all of us.
My lord, you have always believed in us
We will reward your faith. I swear it
I’m afraid faith is not enough
Here we pay a Northern price for a blessing
The gods demand a sacrifice
Lord Ujiri, I pledge that I will do whatever it takes
Yes. We’d give anything for The Six
I know
Forgive me
Kyle! Wake up! Kyle! Kyle!
Norman?
What are you doing—
It’s a trade. We’re making a trade.
A trade?
Why didn’t anyone tell me?
Well...you know...
you did trade for a horse once...
and I think Lord Ujiri doesn’t include you
Ugh! He’s so annoying!
Excuse me. Excuse me!
Get out of my way
No...no...no...
Kyle!
Don’t let them do it
I won’t
This must be some sort of mistake—
He was here for a long time, not a good time
What? Where’s Lord Ujiri?
It will all be over soon
No! I demand to see Lord Ujiri!
Where is Lord Ujiri???
My Lord…you can’t!
You said you wouldn’t!
Gods’ plan
Drake, have you all gone mad?
If we don’t make a trade,
there will be no banners here.
Oh, is that what they said at House Thunder
when they traded away James Harden?
Ah, man. That’s not the same!
Silver Lord, bless this trade,
for it is fair and for the good of the Realm!
How could you do this to your most loyal knight?
Not just him
Also Jake—Jakob…Pole-tull...
Po-ull-tull... Poyttle... Pelt-el...
Him!
Hello!
All right, summon the Trade Raptor!
Ah! Ah! Ahhh!! No! Noooo!!!!
Bye, Jacob Poortle!
It's Jakob Poeltl
Please. I’ll do whatever you ask.
I’ll shoot more threes!
Lord Ujiri! How could you do this?
He’s my best friend!
It’s OK. I’ll be your new best friend.
Shush, Norman!
Kyle...please
Is there any other way?
We tried. They didn’t want you.
Please! Please! I'll try on defense!
I’ll shoot it from anywhere
I’ll shoot it from behind half court
No! No! No! No! Please! Please!
Hi, DeMar!
Oh, hi, Jakob
Wait…WAIT. WAIT!
I almost forgot
We also owe them a first-round pick
Ow. Oh, come on
OK. We’re good. We should be good
Trade Raptor, take these knights to their new house
Wait. DeMar AND a pick?
And Jake Puddle
Argh, get off me!
No! Please, come back! No!
My friend...
Well, whoever we’re getting back…
he’d better be a bloody monster!